we have been asked to compare two
rational numbers 6x 7 and 16 by 19 up
until now we have seen a very logical
way of comparing two rational numbers if
the denominators are the same the
rational number with the greater
numerator is greater and if the
denominators are different we make them
same and then compare the
numerators look at this example the
denominators are different and using a
calculator we see that 6x7 approximately
equals
08571 and 16 by 19 approximately equals
0.842 1 pretty close I would say here
let's look at a simpler way to compare
two rational numbers say we have two
rational numbers a by B and C by D we
assume that the denominator Lors B and D
are positive
integers to compare them we just need to
look at two products first the product
of a and d and second the product of B
and C product of these two and these two
but what do we do with these products
how do these two products help us
compare the two rational
numbers there are three simple things we
need to understand here if a d which is
the product of A and D
is equal to BC the product of B and C
then a by B will also be equal to C by D
If the product of these two integers is
equal to the product of these two
integers then the two rational numbers
will be equal but what if a d is less
than BC simple then a by B will also be
less than C by D and if a d is greater
than BC then a a by B is greater than C
by d That's how simple comparison of
rational numbers is if the products are
equal the rational numbers are equal if
this product is lesser than this one
then the first rational number is
smaller and if this product is greater
than this one then the first rational
number is
larger let's look at an example we saw a
while back we had to compare 6x7 and and
16 by 19 so to compare these two
rational numbers all we need to do is
compare the product of this integer with
this one with the product of this
integer with this one a in this case
will be 6 * 19 and BC will be 7 *
16 6 * 19 is
114 and 7 * 16 is
112 as we can see that 114 is greater
than
112 we can be sure that 6x 7 is greater
than 16 by1
19 that's how simple comparison of
rational numbers is but remember the
denominators have to be positive so what
if we were asked a question like this
compare - 6 by 7 and 16 by
-19 here the denominator of the second
rational number is
negative does that mean we cannot
compare these two rational numbers using
this technique of course we can we just
write the second rational number
differently it's the same as asking us
to compare - 6 by 7 and -6 by1 19 these
two rational numbers have the same value
so keep in mind if the denominators are
positive we can use this technique to
compare the two rational
numbers